come and see what everyone's talking
about
you
la la hamdulillah as-salam-o-alaikum
which means peace be unto you welcome to
another episode of the Deen show we're
here trying to help you understand Islam
which is the fastest going way of life
in the world today and Muslims and I
have two special guests I'm very excited
to introduce my good friend Frank Avila
thank you for having me on again Eddie
thank you for being with us and nomen
Ali Khan said I want to come to LA o
alaikum self Katharine what I just said
was he wished me peace I wished him
peace back and you're watching the D
show so Frank Avila attorney somewhat
involved in politics might run for
president one day I doubt that but who
knows who knows me and Norman Ali Khan
in charge of the professor of the Arabic
at the baina Institute yes all right you
know we're about here and these show
trying to help people understand the
most important fundamental thing in life
trying to have people acknowledge the
existence of God and our duties towards
him and trying to help convey the simple
message that Islam calls the people to
worship the one God the God that created
you the guy that took care of you while
you were in your mother's womb and he's
taking care of you today
he wants you to worship Him alone not to
worship or set up another God besides
him so we have throughout time he has
sent messengers to relay the message on
how he wants us to live and he's made a
barter with the human being if you Bay
got on his terms he's guaranteed you
paradise it's very simple now the last
and final messenger came to mankind the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him and
over 23 years what was compiled was the
Quran so we want to talk to Frank and we
want to talk to no man con about the
Quran Frank Avila he's a devout
Christian Catholic I probably a bad
Catholic bad cat but I try to I do I am
Catholic Christian so how would we as
ones who submit and surrender to one God
as Muslims how would we go about in a
practical way not trying to end up like
we're Pross tell us icing or you know
being pushy how can we talk to Frank
someone like Frank and show them that
this is indeed not the words of Muhammad
this is revealed from the crater that
happens on earth not to just the Arabs
but the whole of mankind and prove to
him give him the evidence that this is
from God in the end spend a lot of salam
ala rasulillah i think that the first
acknowledgement is guidances in the
hands of allah ya human beings can make
their best effort to present evidence
but in the end Allah is the one who
turns the hearts
we have examples of people like Abu Bakr
who when the Prophet Muhammad I said I'm
introduced himself as a messenger there
was no time lag there was no discussion
he immediately accepted Islam and on the
other hand you have moose our Moses
debating with Pharaoh and this dialogue
is going back and forth over and over
and he sees miracles in front of his
eyes yet he's still not willing to
believe so the first acknowledgement of
course is that evidence alone doesn't
lead somebody to guidance it is in the
end their sincerity and then divine
intervention it is Allah who guides and
we ask all of us to be guided it's not
something that we own or anybody else
owns it's the ownership of God it's the
ownership of Allah and we beg we all beg
Allah for guidance so much so that the
Muslim is required in his prayers to ask
Allah for guidance and you don't ask for
something you don't you don't already
have so if I already had guidance I
wouldn't be asking for a thena salat and
was the game guide us too and along the
straight path so this is something we
are in need of as much as anybody else
this is the first thing the second thing
I think the concept of miracles as
understood in Islam as an introductory
point before we even talk about the
Quran is very important I mean put
yourself in these shoes maybe you'll
live a few thousand years ago and your
neighbor who's a nice guy everybody
knows him in the neighborhood respected
gentleman good businessman comes from a
good family he knocks on your door one
day and he tells you that he's a
Messenger of God because an angel came
to him the other night and revealed this
message to him and not only did it
reveal his message to him now he has to
deliver it to the neighbor that the
family to everybody in the society and
on top of this not only do you have to
believe what he's saying you have to
follow every one of his instructions
because they're actually not his
instructions they're God's instructions
and not following them will mean you
will live a cursed life here and eternal
doom in the Hereafter now this is what
your neighbor comes and tells you what's
your immediate
spots I mean the immediate response for
any normal human being is either a
you're crazy be what did you have for
dinner last night yeah you know maybe
he's possessed nowadays we say
psychologically disturbed in the old
days they said he's possessed Yeah right
or he's playing a trick is it can't be
for real so skepticism is the normal
response to at all claim like that and
this is all of the profits all of the
profits claim to be messengers of God
that received revelation that speak on
behalf of the Lord of the Worlds so from
the very beginning what we have to
understand nowadays it's easy to accept
a religion because you have millions of
followers right all over the world
believing the same thing but imagine you
have to be the first one and everybody
around you your entire society says this
man is crazy don't listen to him which
is the same of Jesus Lisa his Saddam and
of Moses as it is of Mohammed Salim so
this is the first thing
messengers put themselves in a very
difficult position not by their own
choice because God gives them the
responsibility and we also know it is
our Creed as Muslims that messengers
prophets and messengers Abraham Moses
Jesus Noah etc etc these are the most
intelligent people that ever lived on
the face of the earth that God picked
the most noble and smart people to do
his task and these people as smart as
they are they would have pretty well
known that if I make this claim to be a
messenger that the response I'm going to
get is in the negative
for the most part yet and it's not like
they're making this casual conversation
on a train ride they're doing this with
their family with their neighbors with
their business partners with their
society with the leaders of their
communities every single day for decades
sometimes centuries in the case of Noah
Noah died sonam right it is almost it
seems an impossible task and in this
impossible position it is understandable
that very very few people believed and
whoever did believe was considered crazy
these are the fanatics and at the end of
the day when it became so difficult for
the messengers to deliver their message
one of the precedences one of the great
legacies of God of Allah is that he
would support his messengers with a
miracle in some cases the miracle would
come early in other cases it would come
late
but it would come it would come to
support their message to make them more
believable if you don't think this is
from me here's a sign so for example for
Muslims Jesus Lisa they said I'm speaks
at the day of his birth and he claims
the innocence of his mother but he's a
day old
this in itself is a miracle proving the
truth that he in fact is a messenger we
learn in the Quran while you and I mahal
kita ba while hikmaíh torrid while in
jail the angel tells Mary in the Quran
that he is going to teach Jesus as a
child he will have knowledge of the
taurah and the injeel the gospel
altogether so he won't have to go study
it to have the knowledge of it he'll be
given the knowledge of it to begin with
which is why he's gonna be able to
correct the rabbis who may have made
alterations at that time to the bible
and he'll be coming after them you've
changed the Word of God etc so prophets
were given remarkable miracles now if
you study the history that is common to
Muslims and Christians and Jews you find
miracles like a staff turning into a
snake or a water party in the case of
Moses or a dead person coming back to
life
or the blind being able to see or a clay
bird being blown into and it turns into
a real bird these are miracles of
prophets that we all believe in the
thing of it is though Muslims believe
that the overwhelming miracle of Islam
of Mohammed slice on them is not
something visual it's this message it's
these words and they're not even given
in the form of a book or tablet or
anything they're their spoken word the
Quran in its original form is spoken
word this is a dramatic departure from
all the miracles of the past I mean if
you talk to someone of similar faith
that Christian Jewish tradition if you
think of miracles they're things
something for the eyes to see for the
most part right a blind person being
able to see again and you know uh
a leper being cured etc but for now this
miracle is not is less for the eyes to
see but for more for the ears to hear so
how can that be miraculous this is the
first question that comes to mind the
the Muslim response to that is number
one the reason for this miracle being an
audible one is because it had to outlive
the life of its messenger we Muslims
believe Mohammed is the final messenger
so I saw them and this message has to be
carried forward now for a believing
follower of Jesus when he tells his
child I saw the dead person come back to
life
I saw the blind being cured with my own
eyes that's a father narrating an eye
witness account that child would narrate
it to his next generation as a family
tradition but after a few generations
it's just a story you could believe it
or you could say I've heard this from my
parents I don't know I didn't see it for
myself which is the skeptic attitude we
have today the final messenger was given
a miracle that you can look into much
after he's gone unlike the miracles of
previous prophets just as a small
example again we believe that Noah
for example normally sonam or actually
let's take Salah
sorry he's an Arab messenger he was
given a she-camel as a miracle that came
out of a boulder it wasn't bored up born
of another camel it was born out of a
boulder now I could tell you that but
you don't have to believe me because you
didn't see it happen right a skeptic
could say well that sounds nice but it's
just another fairy tale this is
mythology Islamic mythology so we were
given something in an Islamic Creed in
the intellectual tradition one
consistent subject for the last fourteen
fifteen hundred years in Islamic
scholarship has been the subject called
a Yasin Quran what that literally means
is the overpowering miraculous power of
the Quran that's what that subject is so
as an introduction what I wanted to
share is we're not talking about the
Quran spiritual power or you know like
you could say a believer could say well
I believe the Old Testament is a miracle
in my heart or a Hindu could say the
Vedas have spiritual miracles performed
in on me yeah well don't we don't mean
it in that spiritual sense we actually
mean it much more in an intellectual
sense in an academic sense so each other
we'll talk about that a little bit so I
want to get Frank involved here tell us
Frank in this book that was compiled
over 23 years it clearly defines who God
is that he's the creator of all the Sun
the Moon Moses Jesus Mohammed he's the
creator of man but he's not a man
doesn't eat sleep he doesn't do any of
these things that men women do that he's
distinct from his creation he created
the creation to clearly defines who God
is and who he isn't it talks about the
purpose of the human's life clearly
defines it it talks about the hereafter
paradise Hellfire has certain things
that
of the human development of the embryo
and the mountains and things in creation
that modern scientists today have
testified that there's no way that this
can come from Mohammed could not have
known these facts about human
development in the seventh century
because most of them were not discovered
until the 20th century that God
transmitted through Mohammed bits of his
knowledge that we have only discovered
for ourselves in recent times 1,400
years ago when the world was immersed in
darkness the Quran was revealed which
brought light to a beleaguered world and
whereas the earlier books came with many
scientific mistakes
due to the hand of man having delve into
them the Quran had none of these
contradictions the world thought there
could be no reconciliation between
religion and science but the Quran
mentioned many scientific facts in great
detail like how a human being developed
in the mother's womb and described other
scientific facts which amazed the
world's renowned scientists and
scientific community scientists have
testified that there's no way that this
can come for a man so I want to get your
response to some of this you got to hang
out with some Muslims and you got to
learn a little bit about Islam so tell
us what do you feel where do you feel
this book came from had to come from
somebody so well there's some there's a
couple concerns I have visa vie the
Quran yes the first thing is is that
different from the Bible the Bible was
compiled over time by different people
so you don't have one author so in the
terms of the Quran you have one author
and that's Mohammed who you consider the
Prophet and not only the prophet but to
see all the prophets and the greatest of
all prophets although I know that some
Muslim sects believe that there have
been prophets after Muhammad but and
most I think mainstream Muslims believe
he would be the seal of the Prophet and
certainly the most important prophet so
the second thing is the interpretation
some Muslims seem to believe in my
reading and you can correct me if I'm
wrong that the Quran is not merely
as you said contextualize that it is the
literal word of God given almost trends
litter ated from the mind of God to the
Prophet Muhammad and that in the case of
the Bible
people are writing at some is mythology
some are parables and stories some are
literal history some are metaphors that
it is through the context of history so
God did not dictate by some Auto
suggestion in terms of at least a
Catholic way we read the Bible it was
interpreted and that is through the lens
of the human being so the human being is
inspired but he writes through the
context of his history and the terms of
the Quran it seems much more dramatic
that it is indeed the literal word out
of God so that's the difference so but
the Bible is the Word of God but not
necessarily the literal word of God is
the word of men inspired by God writing
through the lens of their own language
their own history their own context
their own literary styles etc so the
question to me is is that you make the
claim that God inspired the Prophet
Muhammad to write the Quran however how
do we know that it was God even the
Prophet Muhammad himself and correct me
if I'm wrong at first didn't know if it
was God and there's an Islamic concept
or a concept even in pre-islamic Society
and you had different into different
term but even in Christian or other
societies of the unseen world vision you
know kind of made in a comedy and I
Dream of Jeannie you have a genie I
always thought it was a funny show with
Barbara Eden a very funny show but that
is actually the concept of the Djinn
however the Djinn and most concepts is a
negative type of entity not necessarily
a demon but a negative type of entity so
Mohammed says it's to anger angels
Gabriel the angel Gabriel the same angel
that came to the Virgin Mary so how do
we know that the angel is not a demon is
not a jinn the same thing the founder of
Mormonism Joseph Smith he claims that
the angel Moroni came to him and gave
him a new revelation of Jesus Christ in
the Book of Mormon so he's making a very
similar claim to Islam in the sense that
now we have a new revelation not just
somebody who studied
but actually God coming to somebody I
want no men to answer this so you're
saying the question is that how do we
know three parts to answer but tell me
this so how do we know that it's God who
inspires the Prophet Muhammad and then
the other problem I have with it it's
not just like the Bible of many
different authors inspired by God it is
actually the literal word of God which
makes it much different than the Bible
and much more problematic in my before
he goes into answering tell me just one
thing just hypothetically if you with
full conviction believed that Muhammad
peace be upon him was a messenger and
there was enough evidence because I
believe you're sincere individual would
you accept this as a way of life from
God well this is like the question that
we've talked about another show is if
God created the rock so heavy that he
could pick it up obviously if I believed
that it was the truth then it's the
truth but if I don't believe it's the
truth so the two other things as the two
things that the Quran says aren't
possible that I as a Christian believe
is one is a metaphysical impossibility I
believe that you'd believe sort of the
Jews is the idea of the Incarnation can
God become man and so the Quran says
that that indeed Jesus is not God that
he is a prophet an honored prophet but a
man and then the second issue which I
find more contradictory in terms of
history is the idea of the resurrection
so if a Muslim says well the
resurrection didn't happen because the
Quran said it so it becomes cyclical
argument so the reason that I don't have
that conviction obviously if I believe
that the Quran was truth then I would
believe it still early let's say just
okay one plus one is fifteen let's say
you were taught this from a young age
but let's say now he convinced you that
no one plus one is two would you accept
it or continue a tradition that we you
were used to for years there's some let
me interject here okay there are
multiple issues that he's raised so we
have to try to address each one I mean
if we get a chance to read all of them
but at least we have to attempt the
first thing as a correction or most
lesson Muhammad didn't write the Quran
because he didn't know how to write yeah
and it wasn't compiled in written form
until after it was compiled to some
extent in his lifetime on parchment
leather rock bones of animals but the
primary
archiving of the Quran was memorization
okay so this is the first thing the
second thing actually what you present
as your fundamental intellectual problem
Quran having single source right or the
inspiration coming to one and then on
top of that it being literal not
inspired instead of being the inspired
Word of God it's the literal word of God
these are actually the things that
brought me to my conviction so they
could be the conviction but then where
where does the original where does the
original source saying okay this is a
source now now here's the thing two part
answer the first part is if we
experience if we see something
miraculous at the hands of Moses and we
explain it away as the work of demons it
is possible but actually by saying that
by saying that that was the work of
demons what we're actually kind of
acknowledging is that it was superhuman
that's not possible by a human being
okay now the question remains are there
are two parts one to prove the miracle
itself what makes it miraculous the fact
that it's the literal word of God we
have to show that it's somehow this
language is superior to any human
document beyond a shadow of a doubt to
be able to say this is this can't be
human so let me ask the question why is
the Quran then in your mind more
superior than the Vedas or the
bhagavad-gita or the Bible or the gospel
or any other religious document all
right so like I said and in my first
introduction and when I'm gonna try to
elaborate that point now I didn't get
into that yet Islamic scholarship is
concerned with self with the subject
titled the overpowering miracle of the
Quran for a millennium and a half it had
this studied from many many many many
angles in more recent history you
alluded to it there's a discussion of
scientific phenomenon in the Quran that
could not have been known at the time
and are only now coming to rehash and
and surface for example the move not
having light of its own or two different
kinds of water in the oceans you know
have you water in light water etc these
kinds of things that are alluded to in
the Quran that are not only being
discovered in science but this is a
recent discussion this predates this you
could argue maybe the last 50 70 years
but we're Muslims are holding on to
their creed that the Quran is miraculous
for a millennium and a half that's a
long time without any scientific issues
right the issue is this in speech we
argue that that speech is basically
comprised it comprises two components
style and content and great speech is
that which has meaningful content but
it's presented in marvelous style right
what we're arguing in in the linguistic
study of Quran and this is what's not
easily translated into another language
is because it's the literal word of God
the weight not just what he says but how
he says it makes it miraculous now
that's very difficult to explain to
somebody who doesn't study Arabic and
this makes my job particularly difficult
because I'm trying to say no Quran is
miraculous in a linguistic sense right
and so obviously the language that
Muslims believe is Arabic so much so
that right now this rendition of the
Quran it's cover-to-cover English it's a
translation of the Quran the title says
Quran no Muslim will ever call this
Quran you wouldn't call this a Quran you
would say this is an attempt at the
meanings of the Quran yes at the most
right this is across cultures okay well
let me let me ask you a question on that
so there is a concept in Islam it seems
that the Quran must or should be in
Arabic yes and that because it's a
literal word of God but it seems to me
that and that's not believed by
Christians or some Jews believe that
about Hebrew although it depends but it
seems that and in terms of if Islam is a
universal message that the language is
accidental or incidental so Christians
do not believe that Latin or Greek or
even Hebrew are inherently sacred
languages they're merely languages that
are sacred because of the purpose using
them so you can have the vernacular
language you could have English you
could have historically its laughed and
historically it's Greek historically
it's Hebrew but it's not inherently he
broke but it seems that Hindus do
believe inherently Sanskrit is more holy
yes Arabs believe inherently Arabic
class is more holy and then some Jews
believe inherently Hebrew is more holy
but if you have a universal message to
excellent point now here's the thing you
know you got you have two parts the
Quran is a message to the Muslims a
message for Humanity and it's a miracle
the message has to be translated in
every language and it actually started
happening even in the life of the
Prophet himself the first attempts at a
Hebrew translation of the Bible happened
by a Bernard bus or the Aloha a
companion of the Prophet who learned
Hebrew just to communicate the message
to the Jewish community but the miracle
of the Quran is something limited to the
Arabic in terms of the language there
are other aspects of the miracle like
the scientific phenomenon and that stuff
that can be translated but just to give
you a taste of what I'm talking about
when I first got into this subject and
as I was being raised as a Muslim I was
kind of a skeptic myself and I heard
over and over again that the Quran is an
incredible language unsurpassed language
it's the it's the Marvel of literature
and my first I did I wasn't a student of
Arabic at all and in high school in this
country I just became curious I started
reading the Quran for myself and I found
actually that it was confusing
literature it was moving from subject to
subject tenses were changing context was
changing Sooners were changing in their
historical context there was a lot of
shift and I didn't understand because
coming from a Western point of view you
have a certain view of how you critique
literature right now when I got into
Arabic studies and I I started diving
into this question of what makes the
Quran miraculous I started discovering
things that literally they overpowered
me and I'm still a student of them I
actually teach a seminar that's
traveling the country called divine
speech and the entire intent of the
seminar is to expose the literary marvel
of the Quran to an english-speaking
audience without resorting to Arabic
that's my that's the seminar now just
one example the Quran Muslims believe is
a spoken word it's not written we also
believe that Muhammad didn't know I
didn't have the ability to write we also
know that when he would recite the Quran
there would be dozens of followers and
they would immediately memorize what he
said and it would just spread so there's
no editorial process you can't go back
on what you recited it's gone it's out
there now you can't take it back it's
kind of like sending an email nowadays
right now one just as an example one
phrase in the Quran
that's part of a large discussion is the
phrase wanna Becca [ __ ] in Arabic it
says what Ibaka [ __ ] which means and
declare the greatness only of your Lord
now recall I said something about a
fusion of style and content thus the
content is beautiful and it's part of a
passage in which the signs of the Lord
have been mentioned the struggle has
been mentioned and then the messenger is
being told declare the greatness only of
your Lord what's interesting is the
phrase Horeb Becca FICA bill is a
palindrome in other words it spells
backwards and forwards the same way so
the quran is declaring the greatness of
the Lord in a way in its spelling form
and this is multiple instances in the
spoken quran that it's actually a
linguistic palindrome now when you want
to generate a palindrome in english like
a racecar or Bob or dad or something
like that small one syllable ones are
easy to generate maybe a big word is a
little harder but a sentence it would
take you some time to sit down with
words that are spelled backwards and
forwards and come up with something that
and then even if you do that your
concern isn't your content what's your
concern the spelling so the smelling is
actually dictating your content here you
have multiple instances in the Quran
where this the content hasn't been
altered the content is continued it
flows with the passage and yet the
spelling structure is you know it's a
palindrome it's symmetrical backwards
and forwards the same way and this is
not one these are multiple instances in
the Quran and this is one area of the
many areas of the linguistic marvel of
the Quran the only other thing I want to
comment that's easily understandable
actually two things one from a
historical point of view in the 1600s I
believe this was a profesor of the
Catholic Church had written a paper
about the the great error in the Quran
the great historical error in the Quran
and that refers to you know the Pharaoh
and Moses well Pharaoh in the Quran
tells one of his ministers whose name is
Haman okay he tells him to build him a
tower so he may reach the god of Moses
and you know to discuss with him now
this occurs about four or five times in
the Quran how man is mentioned a total
of six times in the Quran when Christian
and Jewish scholarship came into contact
with this passage the criticism was
the world there's no high man mentioned
in the Bible in association with the
Pharaoh second of all he is he has been
mentioned in the book of Esther's under
the King Xerxes in the story of the
Tower of Babel on Intolerable the famous
story and this is a thousand years after
Moses so it's a completely different
historical era where her man and that
man that man Haman has been mentioned as
building a tower so the obvious alleged
error was that Mohammed mahalo may have
confused these stories that he was kind
of getting from the Christians and Jews
and kind of mixed them together and
presented this and this has been
something that's been reiterated in
Jewish Studies encyclopedia and well let
me break in on here and I am NOT an
expert in this so it's hard for me to
comment on the specific but that there
is allegation that the Quran is bits and
pieces of different Gnostic and
different other religious literature
that was out there at the time
yeah there's no evidence to it and and
the the coherence of the Quran the
cohesion of it as a text is the ultimate
proof to the contrary but just on that
historicity point Maurice BA kua in like
it's about 70 years ago that he engaged
in this study
he said well Jewish history contradicts
what the Quran is saying about Haman and
this tower building let's look at
Egyptology let's look at Egyptian
history because the French and the
Germans at the early part the late part
of the 1800s had already started
translating or are getting into Egyptian
hieroglyphics and reformulating the
language to try to translate some of the
ancient Egyptian texts Egyptology was a
big deal in the early 1900s even so he
travels to speak to some of these
Egyptologists says to them the Quran has
this name Haman as a minister working
for the historical Pharaoh at the time
of Moses that specific Pharaoh the
Egyptologists tell him and this is
actually articulated in his book the
Bible Quran in science that there's no
way this man could have known that name
and we probably it's not even going to
be there because that language the
Egyptian hieroglyphic language was
already dead for a couple of thousand
years nobody knew that language after
translation he goes to Austria and finds
there's actually a list of people that
worked in the the the court of Pharaoh
they find Haman as the chief architect
that's actually found in Egyptology a
name mentioned in the Quran so from the
historical point of view at last comment
on this issue of the miraculous nature
of the Quran the Quran claims in nan de
una zona de coeur we are the ones who
have revealed the ultimate reminder we
meaning we got himself he speaks of
himself in the Royal and he says we've
made the Quran easy for remembrance
we've made the Quran easy for
remembrance and the Quran to this day
the only book that to my knowledge that
is memorized by hundreds of thousands if
not millions of people of all ages
despite their language background in by
the letter from one end of the book to
the other is no Quran without
photographic memory I don't have
photographic memory
I just started learning Arabic in 2000
I've already memorized half the Quran
and this is part-time endeavor you know
in Chicagoland probably you'd find a
couple of hundred kids that have easily
memorized the entire Quran in China
you'll find kids that I remember adults
that I memorize Quran so the fact that
the Quran says that it's miraculously
easy memorized a 600 page document
miraculously easy to memorize and it's
memorized by people from all over the
word by it to the letter in and of
itself as America we're gonna have to
get together again they're signaling
that we are out of time Frank definitely
made more time on these topics yes
absolutely thank you for being with us
Frank
thank you brother Norman Cohn and I like
to thank you for sitting tight to
another episode of the Deen show as you
can see we can sit with our brothers and
humanity and discuss some of these
topics in a civil way and we can agree
to disagree or one day that brother that
you sitting with might acknowledge that
there's only one God and he agrees to
worship the Creator along with all any
associates and that Muhammad is the last
final messenger so with that said we
hope to see you again next time on the
Deen show until then I said on Lake home
peace
you